so the first thing we did is they just
dropped us right out here so we're on
the broom after we finished making our
character of course this is where we
started here so you see the fountain
over there and then right now I'm just
kind of getting a feel for how it feels
to move my character around see those
little kites over there I thought that
was awesome I love those little kites
looks like you have I think the red one
is a lion and then the uh snake there
for Slytherin I'm not sure what the
other one is so then I'm kind of just
talking to the gentleman in avalanche
who was helping me set this up so left
on the d-pad is reveillo and then right
there to jump on your broom you hold L1
and press Circle
so that took a little bit of getting
used to having multiple buttons there
you see it kind of had a weird little
clipping there as you fly through the
kite
but a lot of people did mini games
during this section of gameplay I
explored and I don't know if that was a
great use of my time I'll let you guys
be the judge of that after you've seen
it but I just wanted to fly around
Hogwarts so right now I am flying around
in the I guess you would call it kind of
like the slow mode you're just sort of
going around I'm not holding down R2 so
there's no speed boost there so if you
think this looks slow A little sluggish
right there that is when I hold R2 and
so you see the wind kind of start to
move a little bit faster around my
character even hear it as well that is
what I'm holding R2 and I'm like okay
this feels much better now because at
first it felt a little bit sluggish I
mean not it was still controlling well
but it just felt I don't know kind of
heavy weighty if that makes sense which
I think is the intent you know they said
when they designed this they didn't want
it to feel like the very modern brooms
of Harry Potter's day you know the
firebold and the Nimbus and all that so
it's supposed to feel that way however
when you hold R2 it feels much better
and so right now I've just you can see
me kind of spinning the camera around
dude I was so excited to see that it was
running so smoothly because all the
footage at least I I think all the
footage that we had seen up until this
point was probably running on like
Fidelity mode on the PS5 but they were
kind enough the folks at WB were kind
enough to let us switch over to the
performance mode now right there that
little icon
I wish I had flown down to it I heard
that some other people who got to play
did and you couldn't actually do that
game anyway
now if you fly down right here so I
pointed this out in my preview video but
you can see them practicing so it looks
like a Slytherin and a Hufflepuff I
think and then some ravenclaws over
there
and then I wish I'd oh there's so many
things I wish I had done looking back on
it now but you guys have to understand I
mean the way this was set up there were
certain things they wanted us to see and
they honestly the two hours went by so
quick they didn't want us to waste our
time either so they didn't want us to
basically just fly around and not get to
do anything for two hours so I
understand why they kind of had certain
things they wanted us to see but instead
of doing the mini games I just go why
past the gamekeepers Hut here
and I'll tell you guys a little secret
here
I had been tipped off I won't mention
any names but uh someone had tipped me
off saying that there was a secret
cave or a cavern area that I should try
to find
and so they told me a general idea of
where it was near The Boathouse and in
between the bridge I think is how it was
described so that is what I just go off
searching for right now which it kind of
worked out because you guys are gonna
get to see some just raw just exploring
gameplay like not really going for any
specific mini game or any specific
landmark
just flying around the castle which I
think so many people are gonna enjoy
doing just that so right there I thought
oh maybe it's kind of hidden behind this
waterfall back here so I fly a little
bit closer try to take a peek nope not
back there so like okay well let's let's
kind of keep going around so I start
flying this way
and we're coming up on the section where
the students kind of just spawn in so
you'll get to see that here in a second
which I don't know if that will ever oh
was that it right there on the left
that might have been it maybe it's like
an invisible wall or a wall that kind of
disappears as you get closer to I have
no idea
but yeah right here so see there's no
students here and then as I get close
they kind of just pop in right there
uh and you also if you have a really
good eye I don't know why I flipped the
camera around so quickly I think I was
just so anxious to try swimming that it
didn't even register until after the
fact that oh these students just popped
out of nowhere but if you were able to
pause it really quick you could see that
there was also a howler between them
over there
which I think is a pretty nice touch
that we're gonna see howlers in the game
so swimming confirmed as you guys
already know so I did that for just a
little bit which I've seen in other
videos now that you can actually just
jump right back on your broom from being
in the water which is really cool and I
mean if you think about it what if you
get stranded I don't know way out in the
middle of the lake somewhere and you
need to very quickly get on your broom
it's really nice that they have that
here so I'm still kind of just flying
around getting used to the mechanics
still looking for that little cave I'm
thinking okay maybe you gotta swim into
it there nope nope and then I love the
music that kicks in I love the music now
right here I just take off sprinting for
a little bit because I'm trying to get a
feel for okay how does it feel to Sprint
as you're going between uh the Water
right there and then also the rocky area
and then we're gonna get kind of back
over to the sand here so it's X to jump
no surprise and then we're gonna get
close to there should be some little uh
with these things called up here leeches
I think
and at first I thought that was a snitch
if you guys go back and freeze it for a
second there I thought it was a snitch
it was actually a little dragonfly
but I was thinking man that would be so
cool if there was just a random snitch
flying around that you have to find so I
spot something right there and I thought
oh okay leech juice collect that and
there was something over there they
didn't want us to to show but um you
guys will get to see that in the final
game
so that's why we cut that little section
out and then I go up here to just get
this glorious shot of these stained
glass windows right here this one of my
favorite shots in the whole game I can't
wait to see this at night
just so beautiful I've always loved
stained glass in real life as well
so to get to see it right there for the
first time in Game of course we saw it
in the screenshot before and then you
see some students walking around down
there
and so at this point I'm like okay I
don't really have enough time to do mini
games or whatever let me just try to get
some really awesome shots of Hogwarts
and then the music dude the music I tell
you guys they have just absolutely
nailed it absolutely nailed it so I'm
kind of flying toward the camera here to
give you guys a nice wide shot
oh
dude it is just so beautiful now of
course most of you all know by now we
were limited to just the Hogwarts
grounds so all those mountainous areas I
would have loved to
try to fly there in those directions and
just see what would happen
but we had to stay on the Hogwarts
grounds now an interesting part is
coming up here because the dev that I
was working with or who was assisting me
told me that you could land on certain
places so I don't know if they just had
it turned off you can see how it says
you can't Dismount in here
I don't know if there's something that
was just turned off for the demo and
then here we get a different message
Landing is unavailable right now
so I am pretty sure that in the final
game you will be able to land some
places and I know wizard PhD tried this
in her video as well and she also was
not able to land anywhere and then
you'll see I'm gonna try it here one
more time I go right there yep see still
you can't interwall mounted so we got
like three different explanations
so and then speed up is not available
right now I think I was trying to press
R2
and then we're just going to go and land
in the Transfiguration Courtyard here
but I am pretty sure that in the final
game you will be able to just fly up and
land in certain places
if you're not I would be surprised or
maybe it's like I don't know maybe it's
something you have to unlock so at this
point we had to go on and go inside they
were kind of leading Us in there that
part of the demo was over so now they
let us in here which this area if you
remember from the gameplay showcases
Boston Matson described as the Grand
Central Station of Hogwarts now I had to
go over right away and see this Fountain
because so many people had seen that
prompt and they thought that it meant
you could sit there on the fountain and
so I walked up and instead it is not sit
it is you so you see I press square you
get this little interaction and as that
goes you're gonna see a field guide page
kind of Shimmer then I hit revelio and
then you're able to collect so that's
the central Hall Fountain right there so
these Field Guide Pages you guys are
just gonna be super fun to collect
super fun to collect I mean just in my
gameplay alone I saw several and then
watching other people's gameplay I saw
there were quite a few that I didn't
even spot that were in the area
so here we're going to go over and do
one of the game's side quests or small
puzzle oh
[Music]
so I'll let the characters talk for a
minute here a little distracted at the
moment everyone thinks I'm utterly balmy
Samantha thinks I'm potty
but it's this pain ter I never noticed
it before
I know Hogwarts and I do and
and frame doesn't appear for no reason
something more to this
and giving you guys good look at the
options there have you gained any
insights about the painting since you've
been studying it I did discover that
casting lumos has an effect of some kind
if I have the time I may look could be
intriguing
I've been racking my brains long enough
I hope you'll have better luck than I
have
okay so lumos was kind of our hint for
this
and I want to talk about the void oil
there you go you see lumos and then it's
going to give me a clue I should look
around it's this final location depicted
in the painting now you'll also notice
on the mini-map that it has these yellow
dots kind of leading you to the area
I can't decide if I like that yet or not
I almost like it or think I would like
it better
if you just had to kind of remember
but then maybe that would make it too
hard I don't know I don't know I mean
this obviously this one was here
prepared for us
this is where they wanted us to go the
painting
so maybe they're going to be some more
difficult ones so I tried accio I
thought maybe you have to accio them off
pick it up but no it's lumos again
let's get you back to you and then it's
going to start flying around right there
and you can see I'm I'm eyeing that
other field guy page I'm like oh I want
to go after that one too which you'll
see me capture a couple more of those
here in a second
but as far as the voice acting goes I
feel like it is much improved in terms
of the facial animations
facial capture I do feel like it was
much improved
still not quite there you know not quite
there I feel like it's just a little bit
off
but again some of that you know maybe it
could be the capture as well
but seeing how much it already improved
I have that painting high hopes
I wanted to see that choose that just to
see what would happen just
she gets a little upset
I am only joking
we found the location depicted in the
painting and then I cast lumos the scarf
looks so good all very logical the
textures on the scarf pity I was so
close to solving it you have a knack for
solving riddles
Matty's good at that too
so is a meat although he does tend to
over explain
well I'm glad someone figured it out so
a meat we get the correct pronunciation
there I've been saying omit all this
time so look I walk right up to the
bench you guys I walked right up to it
for you
and it does not appear that we're gonna
be able to sit see there's a chair too
so I'm looking all around like is there
anywhere we can sit I walk over to that
one and I know there's there's a fair
number of people who want to know that I
personally
am not that upset by it I do not want to
be sitting in this game man I'm gonna be
too busy exploring I guess technically
you can't sit on your broom and you can
sit on the hippogriffs that sort of
thing okay so I had to go back I wanted
to get that page right there and it's
actually really fun really fun to go
after the pages now that little dot you
see that shows up when you press L2 and
so it's sort of like a a free look mode
I guess and I'm so I'm kind of talking
him about that and you're gonna see a
brief loading screen right there before
I go into the library just a very very
brief loading screen
we'll talk about that another time here
this was just breathtaking walking in
here so I'm kind of I'm testing this out
I'm like can I use L2 to aim a little
better and so that's what I was trying
to do right there
I would suggest not I think that L2 is
really for more like a free look I don't
think it's like a free aim if that makes
sense it's really more for you to kind
of just look around
if you want to just keep your character
stationary for a bit
now I was really getting annoyed by this
field guide page because I couldn't find
it you see me looking all around I'm
like it was right there where did it go
so as I get up here I just decide okay
might as well take in this gorgeous
architecture and then you can see the
sun shining through on the outside over
there got some portraits over here which
the portraits are gonna be super fun I
mean
super fun to check out and see which
ones are moving if they've changed
throughout the game
all this I just thought looked
incredible just looked incredible
dueling loss throughout the game and
then you get a NPC just appearing behind
me now those two you see that they were
in different houses but they looked like
the same character model
what I have found so interesting
watching other people's gameplay is just
the variety of the NPCs like sometimes
out there in the little Grand Central
Station area I see people in quidditch
robes and other times I see just normal
students so it seems completely
randomized so I don't know if maybe they
need to kind of change up the
randomization algorithm or what I don't
know I don't know how it works exactly
but if there's any way they can try to
make it so they don't appear in the same
spot I had to try and sendio right there
I was just curious I really wanted to
sort of try to interact with all the
objects so right there I got accio it
actually responded a little bit with
that frame right there but then you saw
when I was just casting the basic shot
nothing was really reacting so I don't
think that you can just run around and
Blasting students now that little chime
did you guys hear that I think that
means there's a secret in the area don't
know if it's a field there we go I
finally spotted the field guy page
completely across the library
and you can see I didn't use L2 to aim
that time I just was able to
use the right stick and grab it and I
love the the flu flames right there the
little sound you get from ignatia
wildsmith as she uh talks about before
she invented flu powder
which I don't think they had those
turned on for this demo that watch right
here
brief loading screen again
so it's very possible that when you're
going into a large area or completely
new section something like that that you
will see brief loading screens hopefully
I mean fingers crossed I love if the day
one patch makes it even better because
then you can see right here go through
that door nothing so now we're in the
herbology greenhouse area and the music
changes I love the subtle music change
they really did a great job I know I'm
like a broken record talking about the
music but I just think they did such a
great job with it so that right there
you can see I think it was up on the
d-pad if you are tracking a quest You'll
see a golden trail that appears so there
we get another blue flame
and you can see why I don't think it's
active because I was standing right
there and I'm gonna walk back yep there
I go walked back over and it doesn't
give me any option to interact or
anything so I don't think it was
available for the demo level one lock
right here you'll get a chance a bit
later to see how the alohomora works
then we're just kind of taking in the
greenhouse area here which looks
gorgeous I asked them I said so is it
possible that I can find Professor
garlic down here and they said yes but
they also told me she won't always be in
here she will either be here sometimes
she's in the Great Hall which we didn't
get to see the Great Hall I really wish
we had gotten a chance to go into the
great hall because man I guess they're
kind of saving that for when we actually
get the game right because that is going
to be an epic moment going on the Great
Hall for the first time just such an
iconic area of the series so you can see
there are a few students moving around
here through the herbology greenhouse
not a lot but a few students but I was
really curious about because we were in
the greenhouse garlic in particular I
was trying to get at sort of what kind
of routine
do the characters go through
specifically the characters who aren't
just the random NPCs like Professor
garlic of course who's gonna be one of
the main characters in the game I didn't
see her I was not able to find her here
during my playthrough
but I did think that was cool that they
talked about sometimes she could be here
sometimes she could be in the Great Hall
I think it'd be cool if they show up
other places too I mean if she
if they had their own routines I mean I
don't know man I don't know how hard
that is to program in I'm sure it's
pretty difficult handy resource indeed
there you can see Wild Smith making
another comment
but just having all I mean most of the
time in my playthrough I felt like the
NPCs was a pretty good variety there
were only a couple times where I noticed
like oh that was almost the exact same
person or the exact same character model
but then I saw my buddy James expecto
ghost footage he had a moment where two
identical I think they even had the same
robes were sitting directly beside each
other now here we go back out into the
central area and I loved just listening
in on these conversations as I grabbed
another field guy page I'll tell you
dude it's so fun to go after those field
guy pages
so you can see we got two students over
on the right there and then I'm just
kind of listening in the people sitting
around the fountain here
making a comment about Professor heckett
right there
and then I if you saw that little
transition there was a part where I
pulled up a menu so they didn't want us
to show any menus
well like see the student right there on
the right kind of they had their wand
out like they were trying to practice a
little bit
talking about Headmaster black of course
okay right now so when I went into the
menu and you guys weren't able to see
that because we had to cut the menus out
I marked a quest and so you can see it
says talk to Luke and bradleby so when I
hold the d-pad up that is what gave me
this marker and so or I guess the really
the path to that Quest and so right here
this door is where I encounter the
biggest loading which is not it's not
bad loading time but I was just
I see I back up is that supposed to
happen and then finally the doors do
open up so it's not bad but I could see
if that happens a lot it might take some
people out of the experience but it's
weird though because then like this one
right here which it seems like we're
about to go into another fairly large
area
defense against the dark arts Tower it
just opens right up now I wish I had
thought you see that little
I think it's a portrait on the left
there
if I had tried lumos on that is it like
another moth painting
there were so many little sounds and
other things as I watched the footage
back that I really wish I'd went to
explore more of but again it was kind of
a guided tour a guided demo
so we had a little bit of free reign but
it wasn't just total free reign so there
you get a good look at the wizard statue
there and I did Skip ahead a little bit
because I think I stopped and was
talking to the Avalanche developer I
tried to break this pot nothing happened
and in this section right here we're
about to get a peeves encounter there he
is so I had to go back
had to go back and watch this
is so good
story of euphraxia mole
this dude just sounds terrified
I tried to help so if you think I'm just
standing there I asked I said is there
anything we can do to interact or help
and they said no
it was granted my privileges be handsome
indeed all right and then yeah I saw
that field guy page so hey let's try a
revelio
[Music]
he uses haunted toilets right there
another level one lock
so I stay the whole time
there we go I don't know why the student
didn't even pick up the books just leave
the books right there
and then I can see the little white
outline I don't know if I like the white
outline
I mean it definitely helps you
notice and spot certain things you see
the other field guy page it was incendio
for that
but then I think on certain things that
you can interact with it doesn't show up
and then I also know there's been a lot
of questions people asking about the HUD
it seems like it's going to be pretty
customizable
you're that person screaming what in the
world and then you got another little
highlight right there which I didn't
have time I wanted to interact with that
one but it was a different spell I think
it may have been levioso
which by the way I've had so many
comments on my other video people saying
it's actually when guardian Leviosa I
know or at least I think some of them
are just trying to make the joke of of
Hermione right Levy oh so not Leviosa
but actually for this game it is a spell
called levioso with the O at the end
it's so it's a little bit different from
Wingardium Leviosa
levioso is purely a levitation spell
whereas when guardium allows you to kind
of move the object around so there you
go now right here before I talk to Luke
and I'm just experimenting with the
Spells a little bit more I tried R1 you
see a little R1 prompt right there it
did not work when I was outside of
battle
so the R1 is the ancient magic throw
Circle makes you roll then I try protago
a little bit here so you guys can get a
look at that
so if you just hold protego you kind of
get your Shield but if you time it just
right when you get that little yellow
above your head
then you can actually deflect so you
fire like a Stupify bag listen to Luke
in here now
I coordinate
crossed once
uh do you think that was sorts it's
invitation early so you must have really
impressed Sebastian
I'm flattered to hear that Sebastian's
not a bad duelist either imagine it's
quite something to see the two of you
Jewel how does cross wands work exactly
you show up I'm actually with other
Duelists and whoever is still standing
in the end wins
determining the school's greatest
duelist once and for all and to liven
things up the winner is awarded the
prize
interested
thank you of course oh yeah you know we
gotta gotta jump in I agree sides in
crossed ones you can deal with a partner
if you like your first time I'll pair
you with Sebastian next time you'll need
to bring a partner along or Jewel alone
so care to step into the ring now our
character talking about dueling and
being a Pastime spectacular that makes
me rethink what we know about the story
like we thought our character starts out
probably not knowing magic right like
why else would they be a fifth year
but that comment makes me wonder
maybe they do know magic some for some
reason somehow some way alright so here
you see breakthrough the yellow Shields
with control spells that's the yellow
coloration like the levitation spell
levioso and then Target with R3 and then
like a lot of games these days Target
with R3 and then you can kind of flick
it left to right
drink up to switch your targets
and so I gotta say I think people are
gonna spend a lot of time in Cross wands
or will need to spend a lot of time in
Cross wands to learn the combat because
it does take a little bit of getting
used to mainly because here's the
biggest thing so right there I use
levioso but now the second that that
characters
Shield comes back well it doesn't happen
right here but there will be a time when
basically I'm waiting on the levios to
cool down
but I don't have the spell even unlocked
yet so I can't even there you go I just
took a weekend well potion all right so
right now they both got their Shields
back so Sebastian hit them with one to
break it
and I'm trying to the devs there he's
telling me combo possibilities so there
you go I break it
and then get rid of that one and then I
think Sebastian finished off the other
yeah so maybe it's this next section
here where I
didn't have the shield fully uh
levioso rather didn't have it fully
positioned ahead recharge this up and
you could be the next school Champion
brilliant Count Me In I shall now it
takes time to organize these deals but
check with me later I may have something
lined up for you again congratulations
on your first crossed ones Victory well
thought
so after we've finished up cross wands
the first round
we're gonna go back over so I'm still
trying to mess with this Barrel I'm like
can I not press R1 and move that
and you can't unless you're in battle at
least in this demo it would not activate
at all so I go back over to talk to him
again and we're gonna try out the
training dummy I did that before I did
my final round of cross once at least
for this demo it's the training dummy
yes let's do it that would be wonderful
be sure to cost all your
so the training dummy I think is going
to be super helpful for teaching people
the combos
so right here you can see cast accio
followed by four consecutive basic
attacks so it's just R2 R2 R2 R2 after
you do the accio or levioso I'm sorry
there you go adioso so you can see it
sped up a little bit that time I was
asking them I said does it have a
Cadence to it like do you have to do it
sort of with a certain rhythm
and it seemed to work when I did it
faster
this time I kind of doing it slow again
want to make sure I get the accio in
right there and then see I sped up there
and it still worked
on
so it's pretty short I don't know how
much you're gonna be able to go back and
use the training dummy I assume that it
will be
you'll be
and then I had enough time to do one
more round so I just go ahead and talk
to him again right away and ask if we
have the
next round of cross wands ready is the
next round of cross the ones all set why
yes it is I'm
[Music]
ready let's do it
and we had the option I should have
picked Nancy I totally should have
picked natsai yes because we just had
Sebastian
but for some reason I just
went to him again
which they don't really factor in I mean
they do participate but you don't hear
them talk too much at least I didn't
feel like
but then you get another prompt right
here telling you how to break through
the Violet Shields they require four
spells to break and then again same
thing with R3 same message as before on
that so now we got three students that
we're going against so I go accio right
away
and we're hitting them with the basic
shot
and then I got a potato in right there
so the jump right there I was actually
trying to dodge roll
I mentioned this in my preview as well
and God of War it's X to dodge
but here it is circle so
it will take me a little bit of getting
used to but it won't be a problem once I
got it down
so if it looks like sometimes I'm just
standing there not doing anything I'm
probably talking to the dev from
Avalanche getting some pointers on how
to
break the shields do the combos I kept
trying to do the I think what I wanted
to do was accio basic shot basic shot
incendio that's the one they were
telling me about
all right let's see if I get it right
here I get it here in a second
so we got the blue or the Violet I guess
they're calling it
so there we go I jumped then Dodge
there's the accio and then the incendio
so the incendio is pretty short range
I think you're probably going to be able
to unlock better versions of it later
that go farther at least I hope so but
what we had right here
I had to be pretty close for incendio to
work so that was pretty cool they were
about to fall and then I hit him with a
levioso and then finally I remembered oh
I do have the ancient magic throw that I
can use with R1 so I finally used that
and you can see that it finished them
off right there Bravo I gave it my old
you did indeed they're the Duelists have
already taken notice of you but after
that last round they'll really have it
in for you you'd better keep practicing
if you want a chance at winning
or at least surviving the next round
I'll let you know when we're ready hope
to see you then there you go so when
I've watched this bag oh the gobstones
I've seen some comments from people
talking about how it looks really dark
in certain areas
I think it might have something to do
with HDR
I think that they had HDR turned off
however
when I have been exporting this footage
which it's really high quality footage
it says hdr on my footage so and then
even on YouTube it says HDR I'm keeping
an eye on her she's safe Poppy I promise
I'm sure the final game will look
correct on your display you know whether
you have HDR or not it was a really like
high quality 4K capture of the game so I
just tried to preserve as much of that
as I possibly could so if you don't want
to see any story stuff
getting into story stuff right now this
is the poppy sweding Mission here
control attack it does somewhat but at
the moment I'm more concerned about what
else you heard the poachers are up to
fair enough
but I hope you'll let me know if I can
be of help especially after what you did
for Highway does the name horntow Hall
mean anything to you I'm afraid not
why what is it the poacher's best kept
secret apparently
the name came up twice but they never
went into detail I also overheard one of
them bragging about all the gold they're
making at the expense of innocent
creatures undoubtedly the poachers spoke
of this area and I thought if we
searched around a bit it might give us
Clues as to what they're doing if you
ever meet my gran this trip never
happened
not to worry poppy if I ever meet your
Gran I shall not speak a word of this I
normally tell her everything she might
be my best friend after hiring but she
knows how I feel about the poachers
she worries I'll do something
ill-advised whatever gave her that there
you go Poppy's showing her Fierce side
which is no surprise no surprise yes I
think she's gonna be a very sweet
character however however when it comes
to poachers harming magical Beast yeah
yeah she's not having it so this part of
the demo the attire was I guess kind of
randomized so it was still my character
but like the blue gloves and the scarf
and the hat that all just appeared and
we didn't have the option to change it
now right there
I think that was some sort of weird
glitch or bug how my character just
jerked from left to right very quickly
yet you choose to wander here
please we don't want any trouble we're
simply passing through
do you take us for fools that we do not
notice more and more of your kind around
here in League with the poachers
we aren't involved with them if anything
we want to see them stopped
I hope for your sake that is true Our
Kind is swiftly losing patience with the
poachers and those they work with
all right so another comment I've seen
from a lot of people is that my
character's voice sounded very robotic
it was certainly I actually ran out of
time in a character creator
on the last page you can adjust the tone
and Pitch why would he think that we had
so I didn't really have a chance to
listen to it before I picked they
literally said oh we gotta move to the
next section and so I said oh let me put
my name in real quick and I just
basically left it exactly where it was
now this part was pretty pretty crazy
coming up right here so I'm gonna grab
the little leaping Toadstool leaping
Toadstool caps
and I'm just trying to take it in right
here you can see yeah start walking
slowly I'm just looking around trying to
give everybody as much of a look as we
could get at this little area right here
which just the scenery I think is
absolutely gorgeous I mean you look at
like the sky box there in the background
got snow on the ground here
and then coming up right here
the dog walk man the sweet little
innocent deer
was that a lot of beasts have been more
aggressive than usual lately yeah I've
noticed that too
appreciate the uh gentleman at Avalanche
pointing me in the right direction on
that one making sure I got the footage
for that so I tried to accio
didn't work which from the series accio
doesn't work on living things
however it can work on humans because it
can violently pull like what they're
wearing so like clothing or armor and
then if they're inside they're gonna
come with it so
I I thought it seemed kind of weird that
you couldn't acco those but I guess by
The lure that would be correct if the
pouches although I think it's also is
Canon that you can apparently accio
Flubber worms
so
there is some gray area there so right
here we're kind of just investigating so
Poppy says we need to search for signs
of poachers revellio guys revelio is
going to be a
frequently used spell they take their
cages and one that actually fits within
the lore right whereas a lot of games
you see they want to give you some kind
of detective mode I'm thinking Batman it
kind of works for Batman but then you
have games like the last of us where
Joel can hear through walls or whatever
here it totally fits totally fits so
revelio will show I believe it's kind of
a yellow gold for loot enemies will show
up in red
and then I think it's blue for Quest
related items so you see right there I
get a majestic School robe as well as 79
gold or galleons
I'm actually not sure if they have
sickles and Canucks in the game anymore
and yes the pronunciation is canutz you
can look it up on Wizarding World I know
a lot of people think the K is silent
nope nope nope right there get a
lavender patch scarf do another revelio
so I actually missed something I go back
for it there you see me kind of skip
ahead there so yeah the blue shows you
quest related metal
seems out of place in a poacher camp
I should tell both really large swords
right there
so we head back over to Poppy and then
that's going to proceed us to the next
part of the mission here
which is why here all sorts of evidence
but I found something else it's Goblin
made I found Goblin armor let's keep
searching but carefully
Merlin only knows what's going on here
so starting to get I don't have some
hints that poachers and a group of
goblins
are working together yep there you go
now I was talking to the developer right
there I'm not sure why that pops up if
that was just part of this demo because
I mean it really didn't seem like she
was that far away from me
and then I've seen some other people's
footage where they try to just kind of
explore a little bit and if you got too
far away from Poppy that would instantly
pop up should we use disillusion I don't
know if that'll be part of the final
game or not you can see how the mini map
all the enemies marked right there let's
get about to lay of the land
and here we have the option for stealth
so I opted to do that go with um not
revelio but the disillusionment charm
and I was also talking to the dev just
about General stealth situations versus
going in you know firing your wand like
crazy
and from what they told me it seems like
the vast majority of Encounters in the
game
are going to give you the option to kind
of approach it how you want now you can
see right here in this scenario the
stealth is going to work out pretty well
for me
in the next section the stealth does not
work out well for me at all
and another thing another thing to point
out here is they were jumping us ahead
pretty far in the game
so we're at level 19 actually I
shouldn't say pretty far we don't know
how far we just know it was quite a jump
from where we were
because now we have all of a sudden
access to eight spells
and he just Falls right off dude I felt
so bad
so much for a good playthrough right you
can see a little L1 and R1 prompt or
ancient magic attack but I'm Gonna Save
that here
and I didn't even know this tool
re-watching if you look down there at
the minimap there looks like there's a
path
up to kind of the
North sort of the top left Northeast
area right now where it's positioned
looked like there were more enemies
there
petrificus totalus is square you can see
so it is not going to be what they call
a slottable spell petrificus is just
going to be an essential spell so I
assume you'll unlock it at some point in
the game and then just always have it
with you
yeah there you go cast another revelio
so we can see the bag right there
so virtually every time I find money in
this demo it was always gold always gold
so that's part of the reason I'm
wondering if they just decided you know
what doing all of the currency is too
much maybe they made it all galleons or
maybe they made it all gold
we do definitely see in state of play
that they originally had them at one
point now right here I was kind of just
testing the boundaries I wanted to see
if I would get caught so you can see I
do get caught they come rushing over
however it doesn't look like they spot
me
they're looking around you can see
they're confused and I'm like okay you
know what ancient magic time blast them
with the lightning
now what I found out about this is
apparently if I had used the ancient
magic throw I could have blown up the
bridge with that Barrel there was a red
Barrel sitting basically right where I'm
standing right now
but it fell off when I did the lightning
attack
however I've since watched some other
people's footage and if you destroy that
bridge you can rebuild it with repair
which I think is so cool so cool so in
mine bridge wasn't destroyed at all
so I didn't even have any need for it
never never saw it cast rebellio quite a
bit here because there's a lot of loot
in this area
and again if you're with me so far our
biggest spoiler is probably coming up at
least as The Story Goes I mean it's not
I don't think it's a huge story spoiler
but if you don't want to know anything
about any of the Side Story or know this
is a main story I guess a main mission
yeah here we go
my jaw dropped my jaw dropped at this
part could not believe it
[Applause]
[Music]
so they're taking a page out of the book
of Goblet of Fire right where Ron's
family had the tent remember when they
go to the Quidditch World Cup and Harry
couldn't believe you walk into the tin
and it was just huge all these rooms
so it looks like a small tent we go in
and yep that's right poppy dragon
fighting ring this is
the name makes sense now I'm a secrecy
no wonder the poachers were in hogsmeade
so much likely taking bets and spreading
the words given how crowded it is here
how could they possibly enjoy this the
centers have every right to be disgusted
with wizard kind
of yep she's getting mad now the
poachers are far too ring with only two
dragons
we should take advantage of most guys
being in the fight and look around
be discreet you especially can't afford
to be spotted
it's like how do we get out of Hogwarts
right now
you especially can't afford to be
spotted now speaking of
and galleons look at that look at that
on the sign I paused and looked at it so
they do still show them in game he was
about to detect me I know you're there
but I quickly hit petrificus
got rid of him and so revelio is gonna
be very very helpful when you're trying
to just go through stealth
so that's what I'm doing right now is
there anything around here anything I
need to collect
don't see anything and then we're gonna
have a couple of enemies down here
loyalist Warriors over there so we got
two goblins on our left
and then a human over on the right
I say and I told the devil because he
was saying if you want you can just
sneak by them you don't have to engage
and I said of course though you're gonna
put that chest right there you're gonna
put the chest right there to entice us
so I'm trying to think okay how can I
so about this as quietly as possible so
I decide to go over take out this wizard
first
because he's a little bit separated from
the others
so we're gonna do he almost caught us to
he was just turning around hit him with
petrificus
and then I'm gonna and look I did you
see him vanish away right there so the
enemies do not stick around the bodies
then we're gonna hit him with a
petrificus
and then I just say you know what let's
go ahead and do an ancient Magic
and it is the one that just absolutely
obliterates it
alliterates him he's just gone just
ripped apart
lavender patch scarf right there so was
it worth it I don't know I guess if you
like lavender and scarves it was worth
it
I'm casting revelio looking around I see
those guys but I don't think
they're in the area I'm at right now now
also note look above
look above you can even see
those little golden ones for the next uh
Loot and I tried to get a little bit of
a view of the Dragons right there for
you looks like a common Welsh green and
I think a Hungarian horntail was the
other one
then you've got some creatures right
there which by the way
you guys are new here man we predicted
the poacher thing so far in advance
that's one thing I nailed there's been
some things we got wrong
some we got right that is one we got
right long long ago there was actually a
frame an individual frame of the first
trailer of this scene right here this
scene right here
and if you stopped it at just the right
frame you could actually see that the
dragon of the fat one though was a chain
oh my God
so poppy season down here says nah we're
not having this we're gonna we're gonna
get this Dragon free
and this is the hybridian black dragon
the dragon that has been featured
throughout the promotional materials I
think that was
really why this was such a cool reveal
they've got the dragon egg seeing that
there are other dragons in the game
right dude it's not just the Meridian
black
and it's because they have them captured
here
in fact that's part of one of the things
that helped me formulate my theory of
poachers and that they were somewhere
near Hogwarts because we saw or saw
evidence at least of creatures that
weren't native to the area all right now
here we get to one of the more
interesting parts of the demo at least
in terms of how people felt about this
mini game so you saw a little cut right
there because I skipped ahead it took me
about a full minute
to actually get this and I even had
someone there explaining it to me so you
have your left stick and your right
stick
and you want to take the left stick and
just keep moving it around that controls
the green one until the bottom right
starts spinning and then you want to
spin the right one or the red one I'm
sorry with your right stick until the
center starts spinning
I'm hoping it will get better with
practice and maybe they could even tweak
the directions or something or surprise
will only buy us increase the let's make
that I don't really know how to word it
because I'm not a Game Dev but it feels
like right now you have to be way too
precise and there's it just it just
takes a little bit to get it now it
could also be one of those things that
the more you do then you're just gonna
it's gonna come second nature so
hopefully that's what it is now this
area I'm kind of trying to decide okay
how do I want to go about this obviously
we want to try to start off with some
stealth maybe we can take out an enemy
or two without even being detected so I
go disillusionment and I'm just kind of
scanning the area I don't know why I
didn't think it's cash regelio right
here but I'm just looking all around you
can see we got enemies up top
and then we've got more dragons right
there
more dragons locked away
and after playing this man I hope
there's another scene where we can go
back and like set them all free wouldn't
that be awesome
so I'm looking around looking at all
that I have to work with and I decide
you know what I'm gonna see if there's
any way I can climb up because my
thought was let's get the guys up top
first because they kind of have that
bird's eye view but then nope
I think I just got too close and that
guy heard me
and at this point the battle is
officially on and this was the most
intense part of the demo by far right
there you can see I got protego got
potato on him of course so the little
green X's those of course represent the
cursed status effect
and so when I hit that second Goblin
with crucio
they basically start sharing damage as
long as they have that green eggs now
the green X is gone
you can see I get a little up close
protego right there so it even works on
the melee attacks now right there oh
yeah I got that one there too there's
one coming up that I just totally missed
now the little button that you have to
press whenever you get suspended like I
just did right there okay that's an
ancient magic L1 and R1 to do that
little slam right there
but whenever you get oh there's the one
there's the one that I didn't block it
does major damage and I have to heal
right away
so we do have poppy here helping us out
fortunately but yeah the button changes
so right there that time it was Circle
sometimes it's Square sometimes it's
triangle sometimes it's X so that that
will keep you on your toes as well
so we accio this one right here
oh that was that was pretty good that
was pretty good
basic shot the roll and then a contringo
but potato is going to be your best
friend
protego and honestly this ancient magic
throw with R1 I should have used that a
lot more
but part of the reason I didn't I mean I
was aware it was there but I really
wanted to try and learn the Combos and
this was one of the coolest moments dude
right the poacher animagus
and I wish I don't know why I didn't
keep the camera on the animagus I wanted
to see the transition or the
transformation rather
and then you can see the battle is
really gonna ramp up right now because
we've got the wolf out
and then we have even more poachers
even more goblins and the Wolf just
starts attacking me from behind I took a
lot of hits right there had to use a
Wigan weld
and so I'm just trying to put some
distance
between me and then I get tired of the
wolf I'm like okay I've had it with the
wolf I've had it with the wolf crucio on
the wolf but you can see just totally
takes the wolf out of the battle for a
bit but then right there do you see that
they transform back into the human form
so crucio did not completely finish them
off and it eventually wore off
there we go
Akio confringo
and then right there I'm like okay we
gotta get rid of this animagus once and
for all do the ancient magic attack
there
and if I haven't mentioned it yet the
red you have to roll you have to roll
potato will not work on the red so
that's why you can see me every time now
I'm just starting to roll so this is
where I started to feel pretty good
thinking okay this is going a lot better
even get that protego right there
ancient magic throw right there as you
can see does quite a bit of damage and
then I just get a little bit too close I
can't hit this Goblin up here because
he's just
yeah right there you can see it's just
hitting the little
wood in front of them so then I back up
there you can see Poppy's plant is doing
work right now and I love this I love
this right here watch the line
is this what they teach in herbology
these days they don't even get to finish
the line before the plant
finishes them off
that I did not pick up on In the Heat of
the Moment but then going back and
watching it now
so funny a lot of the comments that you
see from the characters you're battling
are pretty humorous at times
all right this cut scene's really cool
it's pretty cool
and then all of a sudden they just start
operating in even more of them so I'm
assuming these are from above
they hear what's going on so they start
coming down
wondering because I've watched this
footage what is that box over there
that's just hovering you see the little
Violet around it I don't know if that's
a puzzle or what
these Wizards start attacking
I don't know why we just stand there and
why they didn't think to partake oh but
hey
we made it out
and then we get to see oh man I was
wondering it's like is this Dragon gonna
attack us now are we gonna have to
battle this dragon
but no quick Thinking by our character
hey let's just give the dragon a way out
just give the dragon a way out we'll
back up
and hopefully we're all good
hopefully the dragon will remember us
and our kindness
we gotta get out of here
but I want to know like what happened to
the other dragons right like was it cut
for the demo are there certain things
they didn't show us that will actually
happen or will we go back later and save
the other animals
I don't know that was hebridean black
I'm guessing there we have belongs to
that dragon
and they have a couple more lines here
Greg she wouldn't have left without it
what now
she didn't exactly leave us a calling
card I I don't know
nothing about this day was expected
not the fighting ring the last thing I
planned on was a dragon egg and the
poach saw us which cannot be good
since the dragon we freeze flew off does
that mean a lot of people are wanting to
know about that egg a lot of people are
wanting to know
do we take it to the room of requirement
it'll be hard I already know you can
nurture beats there
we aren't helping ourselves standing
here let's get to everything you guys
just watched if you want to see that
without any commentary whatsoever check
out the video on the right side of your
screen now plenty more Hogwarts Legacy
content coming your way as we head up to
launch as always so much for watching
I'll talk to you again soon